today we've got a sneak peak for what's
in store on the hit animated show
Justice League action plus the future of
the Green Lantern Corps is in jeopardy
so get ready for DC all-access
[Music]
hey guys I'm Jason Edmund how many more
probes the corners of sector two eight
one four to dig up all the latest d c--
news we're kicking things off with some
breaking news from DC's publishing line
this summer brothers mikeandleah all rit
are behind a new one-shot sorry Batman
66 and the Legion of super-heroes in the
issue the Caped Crusader and the Boy
Wonder team up with the teenage heroes
to defeat two dangerous nemec's across
time mark your calendars to pick up your
copy fistula piece has a tenuous hold
between the green and yellow lanterns in
Hal Jordan and the Green Lantern Corps
the lanterns of will and fear unites to
police the universe but before they can
solidify their trust in one another
a visitor from the future arrived with a
terrifying message read up on the time
anomaly and issue a team in starting
tomorrow Jason Todd will soon learn the
secret history of his Amazonian ally
Artemis in Red Hood and the outlaw the
dark Trinity races to the war-torn
Middle East after the boa Gras lays
waste to an entire city but a figure
from Artemis's path leads the team
frozen in their tracks prepare for a
shocking Amazonian history lesson at
issue number 9 tomorrow
Wonder Woman dominated WonderCon this
year with a cosplay meetup dedicated to
chemist Aris greatest hero an army of
cosplayers descended on the DC booth
with costumes that pay tribute to
Diana's various looked over the years
and fans were treated to a surprise
appearance by Wonder Woman director
patty Jenkins it was the perfect review
for 75 years of Wonder Woman Jim Lee's
Wildstorm celebrated its 25th
anniversary here at WonderCon with some
of its most influential creators I've
been part of the studio since day one
and now it's 25 years later you're
saying it and I'm saying it out loud and
I can't believe it's 25 years to be
around 25 years later and still have a
fan base and have all this awesome love
and and passion for what we've created -
so long ago it's amazing
yes we do comics that we do publications
that people want to read but we've also
become this giant large family of
creators that all have each other's back
you know when we came up with a book we
were just going to put out the book of
reprint and maybe some gems that were
never published
as Ben Abernathy start calling up all
the old-time creators that used to work
at Wildstorm a lot of people like no up
create a new story I'll create a brand
new story to Warren Ellis Brian hitch
are doing a basic story exactly which is
Jeff Campbell so hopefully is doing a
gen 13 short which is awesome so all
these memories are kind of being stirred
up and people want to revisit them and
you know the people have really benefit
are gonna be the fans and readers stay
tuned for the Wildstorm 25th anniversary
special bits August Justice League
action sends a super team on lively new
adventures
and takes the entire pantheon of DC
heroes and villains and put them to work
so for today's featured Ford we caught
up with the cast and crew to find out
what the future holds for the hit series
Oh justice league action has a lot of
fun episodes on the rise and there's
leaper in paradise is about lex luthor
coming to the mascara and obtaining a
relic which would give him the powers of
Zeus and then Batman and Superman come
along for the ride which causes some
issues what's really delightful is that
then it gets the chance to see what
happens when a man finds his way on to
Paradise Island this is not so well for
the man thirsty that's right the wish is
that
[Music]
circe you're working with this this man
what can he do for you that you can't do
for yourself for starters I dig balls
guys also he can do that for me
[Music]
it's my hands of Hercules spell she's in
a tight squeeze which I get tighter give
us your staff and we'll let her live I'd
happily give her life and every other
Amazon's before I'd let the two of you
have that kind of power if that's the
way you want it another advantage of man
Hippolyta distraction
each episode you're going to see
something new and ridiculous sometimes
you're watching a TV show and itself
sort of like watching the same TV show
over and over but they slot in new
things and ours we have so many justice
leaguers and so many characters in the
BPU to address that we try to put as
many as 210 in these episodes I really
feel the chance for us to introduce some
these characters to two kids that maybe
don't know them the greatest episode in
the history of DC Comics will be called
field trip is it will be historic
because all the big kids are out
Superman and Wonder Woman is Batman gets
tucked into another dimension per se
maybe I don't know and then me and the
sword the younger crew have to help out
and take over and run the show and we're
not that great at it
but we find a way we find a way to make
magic and really get it done have loved
these characters and many iterations and
this is just a new way and hopefully
unique and fun way
new fans and I love them I think they're
both fun and humorous and still
action-packed intense when they need to
be like a good action movie sugar do you
swear to show the panel of the week the
whole panel the week and nothing but the
panel of the week they'll help you well
I do well that's the news for now but we
have a stack of comics
signed by top DC talent from WonderCon
and Dallas Fan Expo to get one yet plus
we're throwing in rebirth collected
editions of Batgirl Harley Quinn and one
of my favorites Deathstroke have all you
got to do for your chance to win its
head on over to DC Comics dot-com class
watch and win and fill out the form if
as easy as one two there's not even a
three you know what else be subscribing
ADP all-access so make sure you do that
and we'll see you tomorrow Superfriends
[Music]